you
right now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week for the
millions of Americans suffering from
dementia unpaid caregivers such as
family and friends often produce
invaluable assistance a poll out this
week from the University of Michigan
asked these caregivers about their
personal experiences 148 individuals
took part in the survey all of them were
between the ages of 50 and 80 62% were
women and nearly half had another job in
addition to caregiving here to break
down the findings and more is CBS News
contributor dr. Tara Narula
great to see it okay to see you so this
is kind of an unusual study you don't
see a lot of studies about caregivers
what did they find we don't see a lot of
research about it we don't talk about it
enough but this is really a group of
unsung heroes they don't get paid they
don't get a day off they don't get
recognized and many times they're caring
for people who don't recognize them in
this survey 60% of the time it was for
parent 19% of the time was for a spouse
we're not talking about weeks or days
this was for the most part years of
caregiving forty percent of the time for
nine hours or more a day is equivalent
to full-time employment so what was
interesting was that well 78 percent
said that it was stressful eighty-five
percent did in fact find it rewarding
yeah and 91 percent said it gave them
perspective meaning it gave them time to
think about how would they want to have
their caregiving needs met when they
became older so what are their some of
the challenges these caregivers faces
with the pole they're big challenges as
you mentioned this is a group that's
essentially over 50 many have their own
kids many are working 14 percent said
that they did not feel they had the
physical and mental health capable of
taking or the abilities to take care of
someone else 60 percent essentially said
that it took away from their abilities
to deal with their own daily
responsibilities to go to the doctor to
have time with family and friends so
lots of challenges for this group so how
do we help caregivers well we need to
provide them access to resources and
really look at this as a team effort so
we need to do a better job at promoting
social service agencies classes family
therapy essentially anything that can
help support them healthcare providers
need to play a big role too in screening
and asking about caregiving
responsibilities and family and friends
really need to pitch in you know I
recently had a patient in my office for
cardiac um
and when I started talking to her she
broke down in tears and told me she
essentially had started getting all of
these issues a couple years ago when she
gave up her life moved home from Europe
and had to care for her father we spent
the rest of the visit really talking
about how to get her in to see a
therapist recognition and
acknowledgement that these people like
these folks exist and they are dealing
with a lot of duress that's right having
it seems like the first step okay our
next topic the beating of our hearts a
recent study in the journal Circulation
looked at one of the most common types
of irregular heartbeat atrial
fibrillation researchers examine more
than 79,000 patient records from four
studies out of Europe none of the
patients had been diagnosed with the
condition at the start they had a median
age of 49 and were followed for an
average of about 12 years Terry you're
our resident cardiologist what exactly
is atrial fibrillation so this is the
most common arrhythmia essentially the
upper chambers of the heart are supposed
to be synchronously to beat and pump the
blood down to the lower chambers in afib
essentially what happens is those upper
chambers beat irregularly they quiver so
there is not efficient movement of blood
down to those lower chambers which means
it can stagnate in the upper chambers
form clots and those clots can go to the
brain this is why it is puts people at
increased risk of stroke essentially
four to five times increased risk there
are things that are associated that can
increase the risk of developing afib for
instance aging hypertensive heart
disease or if you've had a history of
heart attack heart failure valvular
heart disease obesity alcohol
medications thyroid problems lots of
things that can predispose some people
can be symptomatic they can feel
palpitations shortness of breath chest
pain other people can have no symptoms
and it can be something where it comes
and goes or something that's chronic and
what did this study find and what were
the major findings well the major issue
is that the lifetime prevalence is
really profound it's you know
essentially in this study about 24%
developed a fib by the age of 90 the
incidence increases for men by the time
they're 50 and older for women it's a
decade later 60 and older the incidence
starts to go up it increases mortality
to a great degree so 3 and a half times
increased more Towell in this study and
one of the biggest things that put
people at increased risk was increased
BMI or body mass index
overweight or obese the nice thing about
knowing that is that it is something
that's modifiable so people can work on
getting healthy eating a healthy diet
losing weight and exercising okay
finally there is no crystal ball in
medicine but using technology might help
predict which strains of the flu will
threaten us a new study in the journal
Science Translational Medicine showcases
a proposed flu forecasting model that
incorporates ongoing evolutionary
changes in the virus using past data the
model was able to predict outbreak
levels of a certain strain of the flu
accurately from 2002 to 2016 the hope is
this type of model will help flu
fighting strategies worldwide in the
future yeah really important because
usually we just look at how fast the
virus is traveling and we can't really
assess that until the season starts but
with this you're looking at how it's
mutating and changing and that will give
you an earlier sense the ability to
forecast a little bit earlier it's very
heartening to know that the tech has
helped in recent years in terms of
targeting the right strain that's right
alright get your flu vaccine yeah
everybody get their flu I actually got
my nerve doc dr. Tara Narula great to
see you